Speaker 1: Well, speaking of Donald Trump, he did
a Fox News interview with Bret Baer that you saw
a little bit of from producer Pat Show yesterday
and round two was broadcast it out or something on
Fox News. And so we have more clips from that. And
the moment I have for you now is so dang bizarre,
stunning, humiliating for Trump. And just a moment
on television, you don't see too often where Bret
Baer poses a very good question to Trump based on
something he was bragging about. And Trump just
has a complete confused malfunction, as you're
about to see before I look at that moment with
you. This is from USA Today. Donald Trump pardon
recipient would face the death penalty under his
new. Plan. Part of Donald Trump's record in
office, freeing convicts with long prison
sentences for relatively minor drug offenses, has
run up against one of his 2024 campaign planks
the death penalty for drug dealers. Trump seemed
rattled this week when told that Alice Johnson, a
high profile pardon recipient, would be vulnerable
to execution under his new criminal justice
proposal. Huh, Trump said during an interview
broadcast Tuesday with Fox News anchor Brett Baer
told him that she'd be killed under your plan. And
indeed, confusion was gushing out of Trump in this
moment after he was told that. As the article
noted, Alice Johnson, an individual who was a
nonviolent drug offender who Trump pardoned while
he was president. Under his new proposal that he's
been campaigning on of implementing the death
penalty for drug dealers. She would be someone
subjected to possibly being executed. Take a look.
Speaker 4: As an example.
A woman who you know very well was in jail.
She had 24 more years to serve. She served
for 22 years. She announced Johnson Alice.
She was in the super high quality. Yeah,
I said, how many years? And she was on a telephone
call and they were involved in selling marijuana,
mostly marijuana. And she got like 50 years
in jail. But she'd be killed under your plan,
huh? As a drug dealer? No, no, no. Under
my under that. It would depend on the
severity. It would depend on the state.
Speaker 1: Let's just watch that little
part one more time. That's a level of panic
that you don't see too often for many of these
individuals. But Trump included. Take a look.
Speaker 4: Involved in selling marijuana,
mostly marijuana. And she got like 50 years
in jail. But she'd be killed under your plan,
huh? As a drug dealer? No, no, no. Under my under
that. It would depend on the severity. It would
depend on the state. And she's technically a
former drug dealer. She. She had a multimillion
dollar cocaine ring and a dealer. So even Alice
Johnson in that she can't do it. Okay. By the way,
if that was there, no, she wouldn't
be killed. It would start as of now.
So you wouldn't go to the White House. But as it.
Speaker 1: So this highlights a couple of things.
The first being how incorrect of a policy
proposal that is. But the second being,
and I think we're all very aware of this, even
the thing is, he said he proposed it and he
promotes he doesn't understand to care about
or have any actual substantive belief in based
on some policy analysis. Come on. As if. And so
they're he probably never thought about the fact
that on one end he'll promote the fact that
he pardoned nonviolent drug offenders such as
Alice Johnson. And on the other end, he's talking
about executing people just like Alice Johnson.
And that just there occurred to him based
on Brett Berry's questioning and you saw
the confusion that came of it. But indeed, he
has been promoting at rallies and elsewhere
the idea of the death penalty for drug dealers.
Speaker 4: Is I am calling for the death penalty
for drug dealers and human traffickers,
which will, upon its passage, reduce the
it will reduce drug distribution and.
Speaker 1: And it once again shows us how
everything is for applause. Everything's. How does
this play in this given moment over here? People
kind of liked that I pardoned someone like Alice
Johnson, so I'm going to talk about that. And over
here, people cheer when I say death penalty for
drug dealers. There's no coherence and there's no
policy principle. It's just
for the applause and for
Trump's ego. Here's another example of this.
Speaker 4: And I'm calling on Republicans and
Democrats immediately to institute to get to
Washington and institute the death penalty for
drug dealers. You will no longer have a problem.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So then when those two applause
lines contradict, we get the moment that you just
saw. Complete and total. Confusion and panic.